hello so happy to be here
oh my goodness it's so lovely to see you
in this
iteration you stunning chameleon
thank you so much and it is like a joy
and an honor to see you and meet you in
person uh you're on the
eve of the premiere of this
extraordinary movie it's so beautiful
we're gonna look at a clip if that's all
right of the united states versus billie
holiday um what are we about to see may
i ask andra
um so this is actually when uh
jimmy fletcher uh first is well if he
first meets billie holiday so he's been
trying to get access to her
and so this is their first meeting and
he's
he's really tasked by the fbi to take
her down but you start to see the
beginnings of of his sort of love for
her and and her love for him so this is
their first meeting what's my other song
is just about love
love is important too right
you know one day
i'ma quit the drinking and get off that
stuff
too maybe go to one of those hospitals
you know like judy garland
those movie stars
i would love to start by asking you
what was your research process
how did you embody this extraordinary
woman i keep saying that word
it's um it's hard to find words worthy
of what you did with bringing her to
life
and the life that she lived thank you
i i first of all thank you that means
everything coming from you but i the um
the research process it was
extensive as i'm sort of discovering now
and researching billie holiday is easy
for me i have a love for this woman and
i've loved her since i was 11 years old
so
being able to obsessively you know look
at material about billie holiday every
book
every documentary every photo every
interview every audio clip of her
and then it was also um understanding
addiction right that was a huge part of
it understanding the government's role
in
in black life and in culture and
community and
and uh the war on drugs understanding
the fbi the federal bureau of narcotics
um and then lee working with lee talking
with lee every day and just
about how who he wanted his billy to be
and and
um and and just the different layers of
sort of her
of her humanity and then i worked with
closely with tasha smith who was my
acting coach and
with tom jones who was my dialect coach
to help me really
you know fine-tune her voice and um and
to
inform all of my research with it with
an actual human being as you know
yeah um and then i sat with with
multiple heroin addicts
and and recovering addicts and and
uh and just to understand really the the
the underlying trauma and the mental
illness of addiction that was a huge
huge part of it and um and then
proud of the transformation has lost
almost 40 pounds i
don't smoke or drink but i started
smoking cigarettes and
drinking a lot of gin um
and uh and just generally changing my
behavior being more sexual i'm actually
abstinent and
being just more loose with my with my
words and my language and
just trying to to live as her for for
you know two years three years of my
life
it's evident and it really
pays off and
when you speak of lee um it's lee
daniels the director who was also
nominated for an academy award for his
extraordinary film
there is the word again precious
the way that this film is handled
and i believe the timing of it it goes
from being what could have been
a biopic into what i believe
is the most perfect portrayal of a
history lesson
and i've been a longtime fan i've spent
my whole life listening to billie
holiday in fact i was
playing her when my daughter frankie was
born
she was born to god bless the child
is a very auspicious moment i have a
question
now that you have lived and embodied and
you provide us
with the knowledge and the message of
who billie holiday was
can i ask you how should i listen to her
now
wow first of all
that is an incredible question a huge
question and i've
never ever been asked that before and so
thank you first of all for asking that
that just means a lot
i really want people to just love and to
appreciate her
and understand her as a fighter you know
she didn't want people just to enjoy her
music she wanted people to
she was integrating audiences she was a
civil rights leader and so
i want people when they listen to her
music i want them to think of her in the
conversations of martin luther king of
malcolm x of
you know medgar evers of of james
baldwin of assata shakur
of angela davis so i i want that through
line into now into black lives matter
now to you know patrice cullers to
stacey abrams to
vp kamala harris michelle she's in that
strain and that dna she paved the way so
thank you for asking that thank you
so much for
for this in our lives right now
[Music]